welcome my name is foodie ty welcome to
five it stops online romanian romanian
slave the first item please he yes wow
that is weird item that this red area is
name is gobble flange gobble he's got
nipples they're really can you see that
I'm touching example now this item I
bought from Amazon you can buy it for
500 [ __ ]
500 I spent 500 on this [ __ ] 500 pounds
for this for a joke for a joke that's
not even that funny now he can change
his old oh oh oh and now he's like that
guy from dark weight as that guy from
Star Wars do you know what I mean nah no
no me neither
so these are made to practice CPR I
guess we should do it
should we try it should we try it he's
dying I don't know how to do CPR so I
don't see what the fun point is oh yeah
you gotta hold the nose I forgot about
that
hi skits are so [ __ ] big 5 500 we
spent 500 at least you can get him
name-o
oh yeah are these breasts or can we get
much higher so high to write them there
we go we gonna fix you up make you look
very pretty
he's cute we gonna make you pretty we
gonna make you give him a little bra his
tits are so far down thank you today
ready now next item please
inflatable limbo stick Wow the items
gets better every week
we did not spend our entire budget on
garbled I had you not happy I'm so
[ __ ] tired of inflating [ __ ] there
you go
oh you [ __ ] it's long it oh my god maybe
not like that you're like that Romanian
you [ __ ] [ __ ] I remain singing all
right [ __ ] this electro sex so this is
for your nipples test subject slightly
for Romanian I'm a pig
don't do too much good time
oh [ __ ] is he doing it right away bread
you too yeah Brian bran Kabir I don't
want to do it bread come here okay well
then just find one ah [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] that works
ha ha ha ha it is you need to colonel
your buddy Oh
oh [ __ ] yes quite nice manda huh
bring in the lootcrate
thank you sponsor rahega lootcrate calm
such toots
enter the code kids get 10% off what's
that I am unboxing September's theme
speed order before the 19th to get the
current theme which is horror oh god
dude oh go whoa give Gavin you're
[ __ ] rich this is what it's like to
fit and be a dad you dress your kids
make out with them oh wow
so you always get really cool shirts
with lucre cooties collectible auto
Arnim and we got the flash in the air oh
please not be that arrows [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
god damn it let's put it on the shelf
for now
[Music]
Batman metal bat Winkies chain stealth
edition oh it's the back it's the self
self oh okay it just seems like it would
be painful to have this in your pocket
look at this
you could have went you couldn't put
this in your pants it's a really cool
keychain if you want to rip up your
clothes this is what fashion is all
about you got to have a nipple peeking
out or you're not fashionable next up we
have gone in 60 seconds
it's a movie oh it's a car from the
movie and to top it all off the big item
of this month Battlestar Galactica
Galactica's Battlestar Galactica that's
that's so cool why do you like these
alright bright you got well you can make
a car out of the box that I ruined
because I'm an idiot that's cool this
one's theme is horror so if you want to
order that sounds pretty cool I like
horror stuff halloween is coming up
order before the 19 guys hurry the [ __ ]
up go to Luke Raycom slash boots
enter the code till you get 10% up pep
up I am tired you're Nathan tomorrow yes
yes I am I am a hard worker I do work
really hard on my channel I see you know
I got something for you what it what is
it two tickets to the day spa let's go
[Music]
oh okay is that the thing okay
I have arrived at the sound get in Sona
oh sorry
Oh Papa's in heaven here we go oh oh
[Music]
that's good I feel like a new man
remaining what are you doing what are
you doing oh oh oh oh that's hot my back
is burning I have this thing for my feet
I don't know what to do this but I love
there
oh it's getting it's getting a little
too hot now you could turn it down man
oh oh oh it's getting hot oh oh boy hey
no stop this is just beautiful
ah ah yeah you got it
it's me what are you gonna do what are
you gonna do about it huh
mm-hmm yeah thanks for watching this
video remember to leave a like a thumbs
up it always helps also check out our
sponsor loot crate comm slash pewds and
entered the code parrots and you get 10%
off I'm gonna go now but thanks for
watching and as always
[Music]